hey 42 here ostriches can be trained to
herd sheep welcome to RIF
a hammerhead shark can be rendered
completely immobile for 15 minutes by
turning it over and tickling its tummy
the muscles that close a crocodile's
jaws exert a force equivalent to a truck
falling off a cliff
but the muscles that open them are so
weak that they can be kept short by a
rubber band if a tree were planted for
each coca-cola sold we would reforest
the earth in three years placebos are
30% more effective as an antidote for
depression than drugs
this word is anak T taught for
simplicity the inventor of best before
dates which were originally used for
milk was Al Capone when playing with
female puppies male puppies will often
let them win even if they have a
physical advantage before the
Renaissance three-quarters of all the
books in the world were in Chinese in
2011 the internet reached 13.7 billion
pages one for every year since the Big
Bang wTF is the acronym of the world
Taekwondo Federation 99% of Austrians
are German though most Austrians insists
that they aren't only 35 percent of the
average person's Twitter followers are
actual people 27,000 trees are felled
each day for toilet paper about 200,000
academic journals are published in
English each year the average number of
readers per article is 5 an adult
produces enough hydrogen in their urine
each year to drive a car to
thousand seven hundred kilometers thanks
for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2